hello there reject nation I'm Greg Ella
and I'm John Humphrey we are gonna watch
from new rock stars one of my favorite
YouTube channels in the world today
star wars timeline new timeline
explained Kevin Feige film confirmed I
suppose since there's all these like
Disney Plus announcements with the new
shows Mandalorian Star Wars movies of
course Kevin Feige
got a whole lotta break down this is a
topper war tier video request for a man
named Mikhail Linden so let's get into
it
Kassie an end or other projects and
development I feel like we are in
desperate need of an update to the Star
Wars canonical chronology and we got it
so I'm gonna stick to the big events
that are relevant to these new
properties so I may not catalogue every
canonical Burke from Gaetano damn it
okay big nerd doesn't go by years the
way we mark our years by revolutions of
the earth around the Sun with a calendar
that uses the birth of Christ as your
zero or for somebody I'm sure a Mayan
calendar where the world ended 70 years
ago and of course all the Star Wars
history takes place so for simplicity
sake more compliant earth years to
arguably the biggest event in the star
wars history that we care about the
destruction of the first Death Star in
the Battle of Yavin so we're gonna use
that as our birth of grace gear 0 0 will
be BBY before Battle of Yavin and after
0 will be 80 why after Battle of Yavin
okay so we can rule it a miracle
according to searle report it all
started with a so called wellspring of
life a fourth planet from which
midi-chlorians originated some time
after this in sestra beings invented
hyperspace travel the prime jedi
established the Jedi Order in the first
Jedi Temple on hot 2 and a dark faction
of the Jedi
broke off to eventually form the Sith
and it brings us to the age of the
republic which was formed with its
capital on Khorasan and me temple on
Jetta and rogue one was built 5,000
years before the Battle of Yavin that
Greek temple was built on heaven four
and then eight thousand year was a lot
of work in the Mandalorians yet where's
Amanda Lord began this war would
eventually ravage the circus of
Mandalore forces people to live in these
doing cities really destroy the
Mandalorian scattering them across the
galaxy and leading to one of them being
the star the Mandalorian coming up on
Disney plus years later but then we come
from the period of the Knights of the
Old Republic that Afghan enjoy of the
trilogy of movies based on the popular
game in at least the first movie of
which will be written by the game of
thrones showrunners Benioff and Weiss so
don't be that's still happened is with
in Old Republic transitions to the
Republic governed by the Galactic sent
like the Roman Republic and these days
it seems all democratic forms the
government this Senate collapsed under
the weight of corruption which brings us
to the events of episode 1 but the
answer minutes you know the story here
Anakin Skywalker is discovered by the
Jedi on Tatooine there's an epic mall
and the political drama between the WHO
and the Trade Federation since she
Palpatine to Supreme Chancellor the
Senate's or as he was telling some of
the mirror those days I so ten years
later for the events the clones in which
war breaks out between the separatists
of Count Dooku and the Clone Trooper
army of the Republic which was actually
a war manufactured from times I can't
tell our wars the clone wars is set both
the movie and the series in which Anakin
and obi-wan are joined by ahsoka tano
this series is also known for
resurrecting Maul and shortly after this
construction of the Death Star begins on
Geonosis with plants were seen in attack
of the clones
two years later are the events of
Revenge of the Sith when the Empire
comes into form
Palpatine reveals himself to Anakin
corrupts him into Darth Vader and gives
old killing most of the Jedi Luke and
Leia are born Padme dies and Yoda and
obi-wan go into exile and then eight
years after that will be the events of
the upcoming obi-wan Kenobi series I
don't know much about what it will be
about but obi-wan will be on Tatooine at
this time and since Maul is active the
to my head
rematch doubt it your hatred events is a
second-rate part of a Star Wars story
which introduced Han Solo Chewbacca and
Lando Calrissian in a story that rusted
past small though they didn't know it
then five years after that start the
events of the animated series Star Wars
rebels following kanan jarrus and others
in their missions against the Empire
also during this actually and that
brings us to our Year Zero starting with
the events of rogue one generally
Cassian and/or lead the mission to steal
the Death Star schematics from Skara
leading to a battle in a very close call
with Darth Vader this narrative flows
neatly into the events of the very first
Star Wars film 1977 again we all know
the story here Luke Skywalker obi-wan
Han Chewie
Alfre Leia and use the Death Star plans
to blow it up in the Battle of Yavin
Miki turning point in the Galactic Civil
War so now we're in the after the Battle
of Yavin years avy and three years after
this are the events of the Empire
Strikes Back the Battle of Hoth Luke's
training with Yoda on Dagobah and all
the drama on Cloud City with Lando and
Vader that freezes hun carbonite another
year passes until the events of Return
of the Jedi
Hans rescue in the Battle of Endor which
leads the depths of Palpatine and Vader
in a destruction of the second Death
Star and the beginning of the end for
the Empire and the formation of a new
republic but the Empire is still not
dead yet Palpatine has posthumously
ordered operations cinder or in all
rabbits of the Imperial Navy to
basically dam your video games this
culminates in a battle the coup which
marks the final defeat of the Empire
some Imperial officers do in abbis
campaign and they form the roots of what
is known as the first order a few years
later will be the events of the
Mandalorian played a video game made
every jerk ruins of the Empire it sounds
like this series will shed some light on
the rise of the first order now over the
next few decades the New Republic rules
but the first order is Rison led by
Snoke Ben solo departs was training
under Luke and joins the first order as
kylo Ren also the animated series Star
Wars resistance is beginning during this
time all this leads to the events from
the force awakens in which is the first
order uses Starkiller base to destroy
hosnian prime and several other planets
but Rey our new hero unites with in
Honshu and the resistance led by Leia
and including ace pilot poe dameron to
destroy star killer base and follow a
star map
long lost Luke LeBron Tosh - and the
events of the last Jedi takes place
immediately after this by the end of it
all Luke and smoke are dead add that to
the pile of bodies Han from the force
awakens and the resistance is nearly
wiped out and then technically the
Disney attraction Star Wars Galaxies
edge is set after the Battle of crates
in the last Jedi with the Falcon now
parked at the black spider Brian Johnson
is developing a trilogy of films that
might be future beyond maybe following
that young stable compound Bates and
Kevin Feige Star Wars movie could be set
at any point all we really know at this
point is that he has approached one
big-name actor to play a certain
relearse and everyone this is real or
Star Wars movie will follow Donald
Glover is Lando a live-action ahsoka
tano film comment down below with your
thoughts on me on Instagram and Twitter
and a boss is subscribed to new rock
stars for breakdowns of everything Star
Wars theme for joining me and if mikey
is working on ahsoka tano movie I feel
like a burping contest needs to be part
of the casting well Tom Hollands gonna
play Luke Skywalker yeah of course he's
the perfect match for you know
this video explained a lot of things to
me but you know what it didn't explain
why are they called the first order they
seem like you know like another order
very similar to the orders previous John
yeah it's pretty clear yeah yeah oh I'm
sorry
don't worry Star Wars fans I got your
back
well guys if you haven't subscribed in
new rockstars yeah you should make sure
to do that right away one thing this
video has done I've never really been
too inclined to check out the TV shows
other than the fact that I feel left out
and that it seems like some of the
movies and shows are gonna be riffing on
things that were established and other
TV shows like Clone Wars and rebels I
forgot all about resistance until they
brought it up here oh yeah they're like
- I there was another rebels show - that
I saw I think of mr. Sunday movies about
it Clone Wars not the Clone Wars I'm by
genndy tartakovsky who did like Dexter's
Laboratory and Samurai Jack so it's like
a hand-drawn one - especially in the new
age of Star Wars one thing I have come
to appreciate even though I have such
little experience with it is the
expanded universe even though it can be
frustrating and in some ways inhibiting
to stick so closely to a Canon at the
same time the Canon is so broad and like
watching this video is like wow this is
kind of like a history of an actual
place like Lord gangs you know yeah
where it's so detailed and there's so
many events and so many characters who
have appeared in live-action movies and
I had no idea they were in a cartoon er
there were more stories about them yeah
yeah that's for the overwhelming aspect
other comes in but what I really love
about this video is I now feel like I
can actually if I decide to which I
think I just might maybe after Rises
that I have time to do it because
Mandalorian will have come out of
November and rise of Skywalker in
December I think I will go ahead and
just start the franchise a chronological
order based off this time we share
everything yeah and I think I could if I
just start from there then people asked
us to react to it I'm like a take time
to react and edit those videos I won't
ever get it done so it's gonna be too
long of it when we can hire three
editors I'll probably started in the
order of what they establish here with
the TV shows and
whatnot and then move into the movie I
like that be actually a really
interesting unique experience I don't
know anyone who has done that yeah it's
like a totally my like it's I guess if a
fragmented story but yeah it's keeping a
large connected thing going over
multimedia you know which is really yeah
it is really cool but he didn't go into
the books
I know under the comics well cuz what
are they gonna do they're gonna like
zoom in on text you know yeah like swipe
in yeah an illustration somewhere well
they could looks man those are that's
old technology they could have talked
about the Wills they could have talked
about the will how Rises Skywalker's
gonna end in a microbiotic world and
we're gonna discover that the universe
is really controlled by these beings
that feed off the force yeah this this
video should have started before the
force planet even it was a thing you
know that's the real beginning of it is
George Lucas's will birth George Lucas's
birth should have been the beginning and
I would have been great because the
actual twist at the end is gonna be that
all these little micro biotic worlds are
just inside of his head and one's gonna
be a big metaphor for creativity I
wonder if George Lucas some types of
specs and the hair stuff is like what
the hell are you guys talking I would
imagine the George Lucas is a
fascinating life because it's clear that
he's not the most thrilled about what
Star Wars is doing right now and also
there's so much conjecture and fan
feedback that I am fascinated by how he
perceives the public opinions of Star
Wars now you know I've noticed that the
ones who really follow like the TV shows
and such are usually the ones who really
can't get on board with the last Jedi
yes yeah that's not the Clone Wars movie
when it first came out I barely remember
it all I remember is like the cool last
fight that Anakin Skywalker has at the
end of it I've seen all the movies
obviously so I wonder by doing this
experience because I'm a defender of the
last Jedi if I do the whole
chronological experience and then they
go to last Jedi I'm like this is in Star
Wars at all ryan johnson ruined
everything which by the way bringing
that up i think it's totally canned i
don't think it's gonna happen there's
the whole thing with ryan johnson being
like yeah i just figured out time
good rule to working on those to me it
just sounds like mediate talk so that
way they could eventually get to a point
after a rise of Skywalker yeah they can
be like yeah we're not doing it it's
canceled if any often twice one - I feel
like that's how you can as well or
turned into one movie and we'll see cuz
that's the other thing too is they
announced these is we're giving you a
trilogy and we're giving them a trilogy
and that just seemed gung-ho kind of
foolhardy and with Bob iger's memoir
talking about how he felt that they
launched too much at once a throwing us
into a multi-phase universe what so many
other people have tried to do and it's
ironic that they should do it from
within Disney yeah doing the movie
Cinematic Universe I can actually see
why they have a little bit more
difficulty branching out and doing these
other types of things it's like when you
expand the universe within different
mediums comics shows those are the main
games if you expand in that way that
makes perfect sense to me I think where
they have struggled with the movies
specifically people always go 'how come
Marvel can do it but Star Wars can't
I mean Star Wars is a galaxy far far
away it's as huge galaxy so it seems
like you should be able to do it I think
what the issue comes in they didn't
start off the MCU with Ironman one two
and three and then go forward with other
characters it was immediately
established there's Ironman and then in
the same universe there's also the Hulk
and then the same universe there's also
Thor where a Star Wars start off with
Luke and Leia Vader Luke and Vader Luke
evader let's go back and how we got to
Vader the way this franchise the Star
Wars franchise has been established is
with these specific characters I
actually get why the movies have a
harder time truly expanding a cinematic
universe but the universe's expansion
seems to really work in the form of
other mediums yeah we're neck to the
movies I think like when you approach it
from a sense of expanding the Star Wars
universe itself like treating the Star
Wars universe as the main core aspect
instead of these three characters that
kind of drive everything because yeah
exactly there's so much more to Star
Wars than the Skywalker saga as it seems
like all the other media
helped to prove and that's the thing you
also see these fan films popping up that
are legitimately really cool and they're
made by people who are passionate about
the extended Star Wars Canon and so it
does make you think yeah I wonder if I
were to do the same thing would I come
out of the last Jedi or would I still be
looking for a change because yeah the
new Star Wars the Mandalorian things
like that are especially exciting
because they look a bit different ya
know I've been hesitant to start the
shows because a lot of that feeling does
come in with where do I begin I could
just watch it and release they order
when you got such a complex timeline I
feel like watching it in timeline order
would actually be more beneficial yeah
if you're going for the pure academia of
it yeah everything in order I feel like
that's the smartest if you're going just
as like you need an entry point I feel
like if there was a recommendation of
like check this one out because this
will be a great primer to pull you in
and then you know commit yeah in a way I
do love this video and I watch this
every day until the new Skywalker made
alright guys making new rock stars you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell and McHale
thanks for recommending this video to us
buddy so McHale I tend to mention the
same dumb stuff about McHale McHale your
lame means this history it's not
important well it isn't poor about
McHale is that he actually loves a
variety of sports you know he's actually
a huge NHL fan mmm hockey
that's what NHL is for yeah not national
hotdog league as I first but that is a
compelling sport as well McHale have you
ever watched a hot tug eating contest
his favorite team I don't know if this
is a team the Colorado I believe so and
there's the SHL the Swedish Hockey
League where he's not from he's not from
Sweden this is a very niche interests
yes and he also likes to play soccer and
will vary in a motor sports whoa whoa
soccer
you mean football right no you mean
soccer hey Misaki oh yeah that's right
he's not in Sweden more importantly he's
Swedish I've been lied to this whole
time sorry McCarroll I can't go a shout
out without men
you're from Sweden and they you like
James Bond that's that's your thing
that's who you are that's your whole
identity yeah every person I'm gonna be
like tell me more about your country and
what you Swedish Swedish